neben den unendlichen und unerforschten
weiten der ozeane sind die alten
ägyptischen pyramiden wohl das
geheimnisvollste was unsere erde zu
bieten hat noch heute sind so viele
kuriose rätsel um die pyramiden ungelöst
und bringen forschungsteams weltweit um
den schlaf die entschlüsselung der
pyramiden von gizeh ist nicht zuletzt so
komplex weil der älteste erhaltene
bericht über die ganze zwei jahrtausende
nach ihrem bau entstand geheimnisvolle
energiefelder im inneren preußische
liefen und zerbrochene sphinx nasen ihr
habt euch das thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt bei klicks
um science fiction die acht spannendsten
und kuriosesten pyramiden fakten
herzlich willkommen auf der acht
zerstörte oberlies die nase der sphinx
naja dies erkennt sie bestimmt alle
diebe vacherin der pyramiden von gizeh
charakteristisch ist ihre abgebrochene
nase in dem asterix und obelix comic
asterix und kleopatra von 1963 war es
der gallier obelix der diese beim
klettern zerstörte aus versehen teams
von historikerinnen und historiker haben
eine andere theorie
demnach hat ein muslimischer
bilderstürmer im vierzehnten jahrhundert
die nase in voller absicht zerstört sie
was hat es mit der geheimnisvollen
pyramiden energie auf sich ein thema was
besonders diskutiert wird und ihr habt
sicher alle schon einmal davon gehört es
geht um die pyramiden energie demnach
sollen pyramidenförmige gebäude oder
auch ein behälter einen krassen einfluss
auf die darin enthaltenen objekte haben
beispielsweise sollen stumpfe
rasierklingen wieder scharf werden und
lebensmittel dank der mumifizierung
länger haltbar seien seriöse
wissenschaftliche experimente haben aber
bereits mehrmals das gegenteil gezeigt
der mythos der pyramiden energie
jedenfalls ist entzaubert naja aber es
gibt ja noch genügend andere die sechs
auch vom weltraum aus zu sehen die
pyramiden von gizeh in der nähe der
ägyptischen stadt kairo sind mit ihren
4500 jahren nicht nur das älteste
weltwunder der antike sondern auch ein
weltkulturerbe der unesco
im gegensatz zur chinesischen mauer sind
sie sogar von weltraumstationen aus
ziemlich deutlich zu erkennen 5
gebaut von den preußen vielleicht habt
ihr schon mal von den hieroglyphen recht
über dem ursprünglichen eingang der
cheops-pyramide gehört zitat so sprechen
die jeder des königs namen sonne und
fels preußen ist ja zitat ende haben
also vielleicht kann nicht die alten
ägypter sondern die preußen die hände im
spiel
eindeutig nein die hieroglyphen stammen
von dem forscher karl richard lepsius
der damit dem preußischen könig
friedrich wilhelm dem vierten zum
geburtstag gratulierte seine
glückwünsche hat er einfach in die
pyramide gemeißelt heutzutage wäre das
undenkbar und die vier tausende weiterer
pyramiden weltweit schätzungen zufolge
gibt es neben den alten ägyptischen
pyramiden und den pyramiden der mayas in
südamerika wohl noch hunderte weitere
auf der welt vielleicht sogar tausende
beispielsweise wurden weitere pyramiden
auf den kanarischen inseln in arabien
auf den malediven auf dem grund des
atlantischen ozeans und in tibet
entdeckt die meisten von ihnen sind aber
wohl noch unentdeckt und befinden sich
unter der meeresoberfläche in
verlassenen dschungeln oder unter dem
eis der antarktis und dann auch oft
natürlich natürlichen ursprungs denn die
form der pyramide ist keine besonders
komplexe und kommt oft auch ganz
natürlich vor drei bau der pyramiden ein
unlösbares rätsel stellt euch das mal
vor die pyramiden sind mehr als 4500
jahre alt und damit das einzige
weltwunder der antike das sehr tausende
überdauert hat und trotzdem gibt ihr bau
forschungsteams weltweit große rätsel
auf fest steht nur es sind bau technisch
gesehen vollkommene meisterleistung doch
wie genau wurde sie gebaut es gibt
vermutungen nach denen beim bau der
cheops pyramide von der westlichen seite
her eine lange rampe genutzt wurde
darüber wurden dann vielleicht die 50
tonnen schweren deck blöcke für die
grabkammer transportiert im oberen
bereich wurden theorien zur folge spiral
rampen genutzt in antiken berichten ist
von hebel kennen die rede
eventuell wurden die steinblöcke direkt
an der pyramide aber auch mit winden
hochgezogen wie ihr seht es gibt viele
theorien aber eindeutige beweise fehlen
auf der zwei bedroht von
luftverschmutzung und wüstensand ich
habe schon erwähnt die pyramiden von
gizeh sind ja 4500 jahre alt und so lang
hat sie eigentlich nichts erschüttern
können so wurde über
jahrhundert hinweg der weiße kalkstein
geplündert mit dem die pyramiden
verkleidet waren doch die bedrohung
heutzutage ist eine andere zum einen
lagen der wüstensand und die
luftverschmutzung an der substanz
zudem setzten die vielen besucher und
die resultierende feuchtigkeit im
inneren zu aber vor allem das wachstum
der stadt kairo ist laut unesco welterbe
komitee eine große bedrohung für die
vermieden dass problemmüll wird
abgelagert und verbrannt und die
regierung will eine verkehrsachse bauen
damals noch standen die pyramiden frei
mittlerweile werden sie von der stadt
von drei seiten um schloss expertinnen
und experten fordern eine pufferzone
damit die pyramiden auch die nächsten
jahre überstehen und last but not least
die einst für am ideologie grenz
wissenschaftliche theorien omas er wisse
selbst um die pyramiden ranken sich
unzählige mythen und nicht nur
renommierte forschungsinstitute
beschäftigen sich mit dem thema sondern
auch die so genannten pyramide logan
diese theorien rund um die pyramiden des
alten ägyptens sind pseudo und grenz
wissenschaftlich ihre anhänger nehmen
beispielsweise an dass die pyramiden
exakt so angeordnet wurden dass sie dem
sternbild orion entsprechen die maße der
pyramiden richte sich nach der kreiszahl
pi und dies spreche für eine höhere
macht auf jeden fall wird dort immer
wieder neues entdeckt wenn ihr als
erstes neues zum thema pyramiden
pharaonen und die alten ägypter und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt über mich in der redaktion
vom krieg so mitmachen und es gibt zu
beginn auch ein kleines goodie wenn er
darauf klingt also hier draufklicken der
direkte draht zu mir und natürlich nicht
das aber mit der schwimmer in der glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter dafür
auch draufklicken geheime kammer der
cheops-pyramide entdeckt ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran